keine daten mehr in die usa mit juli hat
der europäische gerichtshof die
datenschutz vereinbarung zwischen der
europäischen union und den usa gekippt
die rede ist vom sogenannten
privacyshield die konsequenzen sind
dramatisch was bedeutet also dieses
urteil für die persönlichen daten von
uns internet userinnen und usern und
droht jetzt ein riesiges datenchaos
klicks um science reviews gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es übrigens auch auf die
ohren als podcast findet ihr clixoom
science in future in der video
beschreibung als links zu spotify und
apple podcast aber passt dabei auf eure
daten auf das datenschutzabkommen mit
dem namen privacyshield ist ein gutes
beispiel für eine vereinbarung von der
man normalerweise nicht so wirklich viel
mitbekommt inhaltlich ist sie allerdings
wirklich wichtig und betrifft würde ich
sagen fast ja wirklich jede und jeden
von uns jede person nämlich die
beispielsweise whatsapp facebook oder
google docs zb benutzt oder aber auch
alle die schon mal was bei amazon
bestellt haben denn wir alle können
davon betroffen sein dass unsere daten
ohne unser wissen in die usa übertragen
werden und so hat das urteil des
europäischen gerichtshofes mitte juli
für wirbel gesorgt es geht um ein
vermeintliches daten schutzschild
zwischen den usa und der eu
was damit zerbricht die große frage mit
der sich die richterinnen und richter
beschäftigen dürfen firmen wie facebook
und so weiter nutzer daten in die usa
übertragen dem urteil vom mitte juli war
ein super langer rechtsstreit
vorausgegangen und der war nicht ohne
denn er zog sich nicht nur über jahre
hinweg sondern war auch
länderübergreifend zum thema geworden
der österreichische jurist und
datenschützer max schrems hatte die
irische datenschutzbehörde aufgefordert
die datenübertragung von facebook von
irland in die usa zu unterbinden seine
argumentation bezog sich vor allem auf
die laschen datenschutzbestimmungen in
den usa diese sind zum vergleich mit den
strengeren datenschutzregeln der eu
nahezu lächerlich oder locker formuliert
das gegenteil von datenschutz
geheimdienste
die nsa greifen alles ab was sie
interessiert und sind dazu explizit
befugt viele fachleute sprechen hier von
einer riesigen massenüberwachung
fraglich ist hierbei auch ob bei dieser
daten abgreifen wright tatsächlich immer
ein anlass dahintersteckt und genau das
ist ja das mit dem datenschutz der in
der europäischen union groß geschrieben
wird nicht vereinbar irland ist der
europäische sitz des us-konzerns
facebook die daten der facebook
userinnen und user die an den
mutterkonzern in den usa weitergeleitet
werden seien dort also nicht angemessen
geschützt und den usa
überwachungsprogramm schutzlos
ausgeliefert so die beanstandung von max
schrems konkret geht es hierbei um
personenbezogene daten wie informationen
zum namen standort oder auch die
ip-adresse wir erinnern uns alle an die
enthüllungen von etwa zweiten die vor
einigen jahren offenbart hatten dass
facebook usw
sowohl der nsa als auch dem fbi zugang
zu den daten gewähren muss die userinnen
und user haben keinerlei möglichkeiten
dagegen vorzugehen der visit our hatte
offengelegt dass die nsa als großer
daten staubsauger unterwegs ist und im
großen stil daten von google apple
facebook yahoo und weiteren unternehmen
absaugt und diese dann auch anderen us
behörden zur verfügung stellt vor fünf
jahren 2015 hatte max schreibens seinen
ersten großen erfolg gefeiert seine
klage führte damals dazu dass das so
genannte safe harbor abkommen zwischen
der eu und der usa gekippt und für
ungültig erklärt worden war
das safe harbor abkommen war
ursprünglich dafür eingeführt worden um
die einhaltung von datenschutz
grundsätzen zu sichern
die us unternehmen mussten sich dazu
öffentlich bekennen und so sollten die
daten auch in den usa ähnlich gut
geschützt sein wie es der europäische
datenschutz tut doch das safe harbor
abkommen wurde stark kritisiert denn die
einhaltung der datenschutz standards
wurde nicht kontrolliert lediglich die
behauptung der unternehmen dass sie die
datenschutz grundsätze anerkennen
reichte aus um in eine liste des us
handelsministeriums aufgenommen zu
werden
das große problem die umsetzung dieser
prinzipien wohin nicht überprüft also
hinzu kam dass die us-gesetze
staatlichen behörden den zugriff auf
gespeicherte daten erlauben abschnitt
702 des amerikanischen foren
surveillance act
regelt dass nicht nur die unternehmen
selbst sondern auch die us-geheimdienste
die daten ausländischer userinnen und
user durchforsten dürfen und das sogar
ohne richterlichen beschluss hinzu kommt
die betroffenen selbst werden darüber
informiert snowden hatte ja hinreichend
offengelegt dass die geheimdienste das
auch fleißig tun auch wenn sich dieses
os gesetz ganz genau genommen nur auf
unternehmen bezieht die elektronische
dienstleistungen wie etwa einen cloud
speicher anbieten doch
datenübertragungen sind komplex und so
genannten gut und gerne auch mal die
daten von diensten und anbietern bei den
geheimdiensten gut vorstellbar also dass
das eine oder andere dokument von dir
oder mir oder einem anderen eu bürger
von den geheimdiensten gespeichert wurde
zumindest wird es durch die geltenden
regelungen nicht verhindert und das
verstößt ganz klar gegen das recht auf
schutz der privatsphäre das in der
europäischen union eine enorm hohe
bedeutung genießen das ist auch gut so
der europäische gerichtshof hatte das
safe harbor abkommen in seinem urteil
von 2015 also für ungültig erklärt safe
harbor für keineswegs zu einem
vergleichbaren schutzniveau in den usa
und der eu als nachfolger für dieses
abkommen hatte die eu kommission dann
den privacyshield ausgehandelt dass dann
vor vier jahren 2016 in kraft getreten
war im gegensatz zur safe harbor waren
einige punkte optimiert worden
beispielsweise gab es nun eine
ombudsstelle im us-außenministerium die
sich um die beschwerden von bürgerinnen
und bürgern kümmern sollte
und das unabhängig von den
us-geheimdiensten zudem wurden auch die
anforderungen und die
informationspflichten etwas verschärft
doch vielen fachleuten reichte das noch
lange nicht aus auf der website
netzpolitik.org ist von einer zitat
geänderten verpackung und neuem logo und
claim die rede max schrems hatte im
vorfeld bemängelt dass man als
europäerin oder europäer einfach durch
die us-gesetze falle die die us
bürgerinnen und bürger vor überwachung
schützen hier gab das olg hamm dem
datenschützer recht anders als die
eu-kommission sehen die richterinnen und
richter ist in ihrem urteil als erwiesen
an dass das datenschutzabkommen
privacyshield zitat den erfordernissen
der nationalen sicherheit des
öffentlichen interesses und der
einhaltung des amerikanischen rechts
vorrang einräume denn die wichtigste
aussage des bgh-urteils von 2015 galt
und gilt natürlich nach wie vor bereits
hier hatten die richterinnen und richter
unmissverständlich klar gemacht dass
daten von eu internet userinnen und user
nur dann in die usa übertragen werden
dürfen wenn sie zitat angemessen
geschützt sind und das bedeutet in etwa
so viel wie so gut geschützt wie hier in
der europäischen union heißt also die
neuen vereinbarungen des vermeintlichen
datenschutz abkommens privacyshield
waren im klartext gesprochen von anfang
an grotesk diese datenschutz
vereinbarung hatte ihren namen
tatsächlich nicht verdient denn die
privatsphäre der bürgerinnen und bürger
wird somit keineswegs geschützt das
bemängelt nun auch der europäische
gerichtshof in dem aktuellen urteil vom
mitte juli also vom 16 07 20 20 der
europäische gerichtshof bemängelt sogar
dass die übermittlung personenbezogener
daten in die usa zitat eingriffe in die
grundrechte ermögliche dazu die reaktion
von max schrems ich bin sehr glücklich
über das urteil unsere argumente wurden
bestätigt das ist ein totaler schlag für
die irische die pc und facebook es steht
nun fest dass die usa ihre
überwachungsgesetze grundlegend ändern
müssen wenn us unternehmen weiterhin
eine rolle auf dem eu-markt spielen
wollen kurz zur erklärung die pc ist die
abkürzung für die data protection
comission gemeint ist also hier die
datenschutzbehörde in irland der
europäische gerichtshof erwähnt in
seinem urteil noch einmal ausdrücklich
die standard vertragsklauseln standard
contractual places scc es die firma
alternativ zum privacyshield nutzen
können das ok habe betont allerdings
ausdrücklich dass die unternehmen trotz
der scc es überprüfen müssen ob die
grundsätze des europäischen
datenschutzrechtes im ziel an
eingehalten werden hierbei handelt es
sich quasi um eine art rechtliche
vorlage die die europäische union mal
bezüglich der datenübermittlung erstellt
hatte heißt also im klartext sowohl der
der personenbezogene daten in die usa
vermittelt als auch der der diese daten
empfängt muss diese datenübertragung
zunächst überprüfen und zwar daraufhin
ob ein ähnlicher datenschutz
gewährleistet ist falls dies nicht der
fall ist darf der exporteur keine
datenübermittlung
beispiel von facebook heißt das also
dass die europäische facebook tochter
vor der übermittlung von
personenbezogenen daten in die usa
zunächst mit ihrem mutterkonzern
überprüfen muss ob ein angemessenes
datenschutzniveau gewährleistet des max
schrems und seine datenschutz
organisation neu interpretieren das
aktuelle urteil des europäischen
gerichtshofes so dass zwischen facebook
irland und facebook in keine
personenbezogenen daten mehr
ausgetauscht werden dürfen denn
schließlich sei das schutzniveau in den
usa ja nicht gegeben
das urteil macht deutlich dass
unternehmen die scc es nicht nur
unterzeichnen können sondern auch prüfen
müssen ob sie in der praxis eingehalten
werden können seiner lesart zufolge sind
also die standard vertragsklauseln also
von keinem unternehmen mehr zu nutzen
die unter us überwachung stehen nur wenn
kein recht kollidiert seien diese
standard vertragsklauseln schrems
zufolge noch anwendbar
was bedeutet dieses neue urteil jetzt
für die europäischen internet
nutzerinnen und nutzer klar ist ihnen
steht es weiterhin frei ob sie
personenbezogene daten an us firmen
übertragen wollen dass es beispielsweise
der fall wenn wir einen us
cloud-basierten dienst in anspruch
nehmen oder aber auf eine us-website
surfen unternehmen steht auch weiterhin
frei daten in den usa zu verarbeiten
bei einer hotelbuchung in washington
oder new york wäre das ja auch gar nicht
anders möglich was sich aber ändert
unternehmen ist es nun nicht mehr
erlaubt personenbezogene daten in die
usa zum ermitteln nur weil es für sie
die einfachste lösung ist vorgesehen ist
nun dass sie zunächst nach alternativen
ausschau halten müssen
denkbar wäre beispielsweise der bau
eines rechenzentrums in europa ansonsten
drohen strafen geldbußen von bis zu 20
millionen euro oder noch mehr bis zu
vier prozent des gesamten jahresumsatzes
eines unternehmens das neue urteil hat
jedenfalls folgen für viele unternehmen
und nicht nur für facebook tausende von
ihnen setzen auf dem privacyshield aus
europa beispielsweise sind dass all die
telefonica und siemens die international
association of privacy professional ist
eine weltweite vereinigung von
datenschützern befürchteten folgen
demnach führt die entscheidung des ogh
dazu dass zehntausende unternehmen um
die legale möglichkeit gebracht würden
transatlantische geschäfte im wert von
billionen von dollar zu machen
der it-verband bitkom befürchtet ein
zitat datenchaos denn nun seit zum
zweiten mal eine der rechtsgrundlagen
für transatlantische datentransfers
weggefallen auch die standard
vertragsklauseln seien keine sichere
basis mehr und der verband befürchtet
eine massive rechtsunsicherheit die
unternehmen die bislang auf das
privacyshield gesetzt hatten müssten nun
schnell auf andere verfahren umsteigen
die meisten datenschützerin und
datenschützer allerdings feiern das
urteil diego arana von der initiative
european digital rights edri bezeichnete
das urteil als zitat einen sieg für die
privatsphäre gegen die massenüberwachung
endlich sein die usa gezwungen die
arbeit und vorgehensweisen ihrer
geheimdienste zu überarbeiten und zu
reformieren
dennoch ist eine sache wirklich
bedauernswert dass der bgh diese zweite
vereinbarung gekickt hat haben wir nicht
etwa der politik zu verdanken
stattdessen kämpft max schrems schon
seit zehn jahren darum die macht von
google facebook und so weiter
einzuschränken
dabei sollte es ja die aufgabe der
politik sein sich für unsere interessen
einzusetzen schlimmes datenleck bei
facebook ja und auch unfreiwillig sind
facebooks daten alles andere als sicher
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen kanal hier klickst sein sind
future ist ja kostenlos also wer findet
den abo button zuerst bis dann bleibt
dran